well it doesn't matter how old you are
how many times you've done it cooking
that holiday meal because there's so
much pressure it can be a little scary
especially if it is your first time yeah
this morning though you're in luck
because we have some tips from the
experts including our very own Candace
Charles who is live at the rizzos in the
southwest Valley with some tasty eats
you can make with the kids Candace good
morning to you
good morning you two good morning folks
Candace Claus is back with a special
treat for you get out your pins get your
PJs on write down these recipes because
I'm going to tell you them really
quickly okay I'm joined by personal
chefs Katie and Nicholas Rizzo thank you
so much for joining us this morning we
got our Junior chefs with us as well
they're part of their this is just what
are we making right now it's
I gotta figure out what exactly this
that's about
Italian yes
it's made with a squidding nice okay
okay now Paxton here is going to show us
how to cut it up I have some interesting
because you guys are open and you goes
kitchen tell us a little Bella so we're
going into the new Cloud kitchens
rainbow 90.
[Music]
you can
okay oh Candace claws sauces looks like
we're having some issues for me to order
as well so uh it's gonna be something
like you can't find here in the valley
and we're going to be uh doing all
different types of shapes and flavors so
we're really good awesome fun okay
Nicholas you gotta tell me a little bit
about the sauce here what's on this
because it's really easy so there is a
pecorino cheese parmigiano reggiano and
then you just put like a black pepper
olive oil and some pasta water okay
simple enough to make okay now the
cooking classes you guys can bring your
little ones too right super fun tell me
really quickly Paxton what is your
favorite part about cooking God cutting
stuff
that is awesome you guys okay I got you
covered with all the details about all
of these dishes we're making I'm already
made cannoli a little bit earlier on our
website 8newsnow.com of course you are
about these two wonderful shelves I'm
there as well as always I'm gonna get
back to cooking you guys I'll see you in
a little bit oh man I wish the Wi-Fi had
not been cutting out a little bit there
but uh cutting stuff done
sounds like something you would say
cutting stuff well I mean I saw your
biscuits for Thanksgiving yeah fair
enough
that was delivered quite well all right
it's 10